[Music]
okay everybody i
am so excited today to be joined by
eliza
schlesinger aka andrea going on paper
how you doing
eliza you said my name right and i was a
little shocked
so thank you hi let me tell you that is
that was the most challenging name and i
made it
a goal to get that right and i really
appreciate it it goes a long way
thank you oh good good so um i was i
love this film good on paper which comes
out on netflix wednesday
so did you did you feel that this being
a personal
story to you that you had to write the
screenplay from the start like was that
always the plan
um it'd be really funny if the plan was
to find someone to lie to me and then
just go from there
um this happened and it was really
horrific
when i found out that that somebody that
was so close to me had been lying it was
such a betrayal
and then you know as a comic i talk
about real life on stage and so
i had definitely talked about this on
stage but i just put pen to paper
this was a cathartic process and of
course you always hope that the things
you write
come to fruition um and i think a lot of
people think
i just decided to make a movie you know
this happened in 2015
i worked on this screenplay quietly in
between auditions weekends on the road
saturday nights alone whatever
for a couple years before i met the
producer uh paul vernon who then
helped me make it even between that it
was a couple years so
it was we had a lot of time to think
about it well i'll tell you when i was
watching this what surprised me the most
was how awesome you had a blend of genre
here there was like mystery
there's suspense and thriller i felt
like a david fincher vibe
and i'm wondering would you ever
consider though
writing a screenplay that's more drama
or just full-on
thriller absolutely this is not the
first screenplay that i've written
um i do a lot of writing i've written a
lot of tv pilots and of course
i wrote my some other sketches on the
eliza slicing your sketch show and i've
written
other tv things um but you know the idea
is that you write all the screenplays
that you want to write and then you
hopefully find the right producers so we
have i'm happy to say we have a couple
of things
waiting in the wings and i think we're
kind of people are waiting to see how
this does i hope it does well
but uh have screenplay will produce so
you guys just let me know but i do have
a dramatic one
in i love it no and what's so cool about
you is you
you really do wear so many hats whether
it's stand-up acting writing screenplays
writing books
and my favorite thing you do currently
is the don't panic pantry cooking show
uh i think it's the theme song that gets
me um so
it's i don't know it's amazing uh but
where does your true heart and soul lie
you do all these things but what what
where is the core for you the core for
me is entertaining people
um getting to grow as an artist i know
that sounds like a cheesy answer
but that is why my career sort of has
this weird path because the answer is
i'm always ready willing and able and
it's really hard to get those yeses
and this screenplay was an example of i
wasn't booking the roles i wanted
um i do a lot of auditioning and you
always you know you don't get something
for one reason or another
so i created my own opportunity and i do
that in stand-up and i do that with my
shows
it is really hard to get people on board
and um all you can do is continue to
throw stuff at the wall
to see what sticks so my passion lies in
evolving as an artist and creating on my
own terms and you're definitely doing
that
and what i think really shows and shines
your personality in this story of good
on paper
is that i always take you as someone
who's i never get phony vibes from and
you embrace that you're very real and i
feel like this film speaks that
why do you think that's important lesson
for people today to be yourself
well you i mean it's funny because the
movie's about so a guy that isn't
himself
you know i always say this whenever i
make a show or something that inevitably
doesn't get a second season um i'd
rather fail on my own terms
then right fail because an executive
told me to be something that i didn't
feel was right
um at least you can sleep at night
knowing that versus oh man i
i really lied and i was inauthentic and
they didn't like me and you're like wait
but that's not me so
you have a story your perspective is
unique what you have to say is valid as
long as you're willing to do the work
and people the biggest rule in comedy
for me is vulnerability
the comedy gods reward vulnerability
because people want to see themselves
reflected so i was
at first nervous to tell the story
because i'm like people are going to
think i'm an idiot but then once i
started sharing it
so many people were like oh my god this
happened to me
so i think there's a power in that
vulnerability
yeah and i think you know everyone not
just your fans but everyone who's just
watching netflix this wednesday
this is going to be uh a great film to
watch
it's all eliza here but it has great
co-stars it's such a great movie
and i hope to talk to you in the future
one day eliza thank you so much for
joining me
thank you for a great interview steve i
appreciate it thanks so much have a
great one